konnichiwa IRA got ogo same eyes we
learned a lot of Japanese a lot of great
things from our Japan trip - his intro I
always do this yay as you may have heard
I finally popped the question
I was thinking between you and Edgar and
I decided last minute I'll go I'll go I
guess I'll go now we're about to get
married now so why don't we do a test
okay to see if we are compatible to get
married or not so this is from marriage
calm I know my saying like they're
sponsoring is what what are your
expectations what are your hopes
what are your thoughts we're gonna be
super compatible and they are gonna be
like get me recently hopefully we'll be
married by the end of this quiz how much
of the time do you feel happy with the
person rarely Oh 50 70 or 90 percent I
agree
pound it brother damn we need to slow
down to get this video to ten minutes do
you agree on the number of kiss you want
to have we haven't even talked about
that you always check here there's like
an Italian way that's like a thing that
kids do that you see like these bold
things on your race that pop up to see
how many kids you you know everyone is
checking right now how many kids are you
I have zero guess that means I'm gonna
get cut the marriage is over
okay so we haven't discussed not really
I think more or less is the answer
though more or less yeah we're on the
same page I don't know yeah there you go
you disagree on a topic how do we solve
this problem
we rarely disagree on things do we yeah
I feel disappointed but avoid fighting
we agreed to disagree
rearranging to start fighting after
trying to compromise we resumed straight
to fighting we agree to disagree I don't
think so
we just explain each other's point of
view that's agreeing to disagree no cuz
then we still find a thing
together and we my god I don't wanna
argue with you right now there you go
how do you find their little quirks well
will be one of your quotes that you
shout in public that's the thing if I
don't record during a day I go crazy it
leads to you shouting in public because
you challenged me to shout something
it's like a penis game yeah but I don't
do it so you just do it for the fun of
it and to see me uncomfortable
I like making you uncomfortable yeah
sometimes is that adorable funny or well
just little oddities or annoying I will
say funny your little quirks is that you
never replace the toilet paper roll what
what's an actual don't touch me this is
not going great then what is in court
for my little Marzia how much you love
Maya funny let's go with planning
comfortable around the apartment no I
always feel like I'm walking on
eggshells geez if you're making a quiz
like this not really yeah most of times
I can reveal my bad habits and weird
part I mean we were talking about poo
right before you proposed yes
yeah maybe a bit too comfortable I would
say literally I'm allowed to pop the
question and you just be like I want I'm
gonna have an amazing pool right now
Felix yes and even notes he's a red flag
in your relationship once multiple times
one's not shirt never I don't know if I
necessarily had like a big big red flag
what me I don't know like necessarily
like that one moment but maybe like yeah
thought about it I guess you haven't
that one time I have what what I do it's
that time that we went to the premiere
yeah and I just blew you on there was
these choice I'm going to get your
picture taken by you know photographers
and being interviewed or going from the
back and just entering the cinema and
you were just like oh we'll see you
inside and you just left me and you just
want to get your I really wanted that
photo I guess well it was more about the
fact that you picked going alone inside
in front of cameras and my getting this
celebrity moment and that was like whoa
am I not your partner I guess it was
good that we you had that because I feel
like it also made me realize what's
actually important hmm I don't think I
saw it at that moment I was like yeah I
want to be in the spot like I couldn't
care less survive that sort of thing nah
maybe that was a red flag for me too
once this is going great
does he or she ever try to limit the
amount of time you spend with other
people sometimes I feel like you're kind
of like you need to be back but this
time no no no my only condition is that
you don't come home drunk not at all
no not go although my partner he's a bit
I'm happy when we're oh that's actually
no we put on some extra pounds does your
partner support you we have some family
oh is that what they mean but they use
money as a picture I guess I'm thinking
a hypothetical scenario what if you got
really fat then I would've proposed to
be exercise together
but then again we already yeah let's
just do that you're running late what's
your partner to reaction they come okay
they call it sounds dinner's getting
cold they don't even notice they make a
big scene yeah yeah that makes sense
last question do you feel excited by the
relationship bassy you yes very much
you are magic just because we have to
like bring up bad stuff from the bench
obviously we have fought like any other
couple we talk about it yeah between us
all right
yeah I think that's how we really
strengthen our relationship yeah and
also a reason why I'm glad like now it's
a probably time because we're we're so
strong because of it yeah I'm glad we
didn't rush into a relationship to I
mean an engagement too soon it's like
we're stronger than now you're on TV I
don't know what to do it's you Channel
and will you be a good wife would you
make a good wife quiz I want to know do
you like to take care of other people
yes yes I would like to try not a
passion no I can't
it's not like I'm taking care of you
we're taking care of each other but yeah
have you volunteered in this field many
times no I guess you would like to try
we meet I gave you seven years yeah your
partner decides he wants to spend an
evening with his best buddies what's
your opinion it's important to give each
other space okay okay I wish we just
said that last time yeah I didn't
realize how often do you nag and
complain in a relationship what is that
what
snag like a small complaint it's not a
mean though is it I feel like you get
frustrated sometimes and maybe that's
something else and then I'm the punching
bag essentially yeah no maybe maybe once
a month but it's like very minor things
like today when Maya finish her food and
he has tons in your office I'm like why
use a food why don't you bring the food
or like maybe I remind you all the time
that you need to make an important call
and you're like oh cool air and I'm like
you really have to call and then
something bad happen maybe once a month
can you still respect your partner if
you do disagree on certain issues yeah
totally that's easy do you lie to family
and friends never how long do you keep
scores and grudges oh man you have the
shortest ride yeah I can't see men like
maybe I just explode yeah and that's it
I I'm the opposite I get angry for a
little longer
well you rarely do it anyway okay do you
enjoy cooking yes that's true are you
emotionally stable most times
most times your husband comes home after
having a day off and he tends to take it
all out on you what is your reaction
like if I come home and I'm pissed off
oh my god that's terrible ask him to
leave home start a fight marriage.com
please no no I understand he's family
that's true I agree do you find it easy
to express your love even during
difficult periods yeah you make a great
wife what is his reaction when you give
him good news like a promotion at work
post it on Facebook and tell everyone
how proud is that would be awful well
depending on what it is of course
congratulate me it says way to go if
it's really important you bring me home
flowers but if not it's systems me you
are frustrated and meet you men for a
bit what
dude he gets it and lets me block some
steam he doesn't like istration but
doesn't say anything it tells me my
issues is not my such a big deal he
starts to fight with me as we said
you're my punching bag I will be your
punching bag anything very tell me five
minutes I don't know what do you do with
him when your mom comes to visit I asked
him to want to go out together all three
of us introduce him to my mother tell
him to come back when my mom leaves hide
him and not even let my mom we can see
how that une Tommy because you made it
seem like she's angry no not like she
thinks that the more she speaks honestly
I've learned a lot of Italian for your
mother speaking to me hey works my fun
cool love family yet had a bad name and
all you want you seem bad and crying
does he know to you yes no you are
invited at a wedding do you take your
boyfriend with yes absolutely there is
not even like me bringing yeah how do
you feel when you're away for a few days
ah because you're away for just a few
days and same when I mean it's just like
we get a few days well we can just do
whatever I like you can check how about
this I miss him but I can still
concentrated on things well you said I
feel fine fine I don't feel fine does he
mind if you leave dirty dishes oh well
you could I cook just now before I even
sit down to eat I had to say you're
doing cuz you've learned everything
we have bring the toes a little bit wait
there was no tofu in it what are you
saying tell them tell them I mean hey
raw meat sweet onion yes he doesn't sing
complain what that Frick you know what
do you want to be in fine you science
absolutely not I hate this question no
it's like if you have to have a plan for
every step of your life it's so stupid
like the fun of life is not knowing
where it's gonna take you yeah but it's
so lame we need to stop asking it we
even know well we want to name our
children I mean I do know I bet if I
ever have a daughter Luna we both like
that name yeah but now we said it so
someone else is gonna steal it no that's
funny hey no one can take it okay so now
like if another youtuber names them
we'll be like we said it first
cuz that happens a lot when other
youtubers do things we want to do and
we're like well thank ya I can't do it
yes but not really but oh the others you
get an excellent job in a new city what
do you do you look for apartment in
there big enough for both of us a
stunning doesn't know what you tell me
it needs time to me incision besides we
have to break up I would do a B and C
yeah that's that for me yeah that will
be like I'm looking for apartment right
now but what if it's a really lame city
follow you I mean I may not be but then
why would you take the job some people
don't get to choose yeah if we didn't
get to I would dad well obviously follow
they just seems like a weird scenario I
won't follow you yeah but I will also go
through B and C as well first I can't
make decisions looks were Cartman yeah
is he willing to help you with menial I
like around the house yes with him even
longer day feels like a date most times
rarely never see most likes everybody
we're getting married
no this is actually the last text I
didn't tell you but this is real if we
didn't get him I would dare I would get
married to Maya let me just finish by
saying I'm so happy and I guess like
we've already been together so long I
didn't know if it was even that change
anything but it it definitely did like
it feels it feels amazing I'm so happy
yes tell them I don't eat sorry what
leave a like if you enjoyed this video
check out the merch it will probably not
be available but it might be bye